this is the reason interview with Nick
[Applause]
[Music]
gese thanks so much for coming out our
guest tonight is David Stockman he is a
former Congressman a two- termer from
Michigan South of Grand
Rapids uh probably best known in the
public uh eye for being Ronald Reagan
First's budget director who made the
naive idealistic and absolutely
wonderful mistake of believing that
Ronald Dragon wanted to cut the sze
scope and spending of government across
the board the you he wanted to cut he
wouldn't say this you would he wanted to
cut the welfare Warfare state right
welfare part yeah and what happened when
you were like okay uh and this is before
we get into his fantastic book a real
stinging critique of Donald Trump uh
Trump's Warren capital ISM uh in
preparing for this you as budget
director you came in and you had to cut
$40 billion from a $700 billion budget
uh in 1981 to give you a sense of how
quaint that is the defense budget now is
above $700 billion I think we may be
approaching that just an interest on the
debt sure but you were
scringy the uh problem was Ronald Reagan
believed in small government
profoundly except for the Pentagon side
of the pomac river and uh you know he
was he was uh really a hawk a real
unreformed
unrequitted requited uh cold war hawk
the defense budget was about 140 billion
when we got there by the time he left it
was 350 billion massive increase on the
theory that the Soviet Union was
developing first right capability none
of that was true that was the
origination of the whole Neil con view
of the world that's where all these
characters originally got their stake
their start in the process and so by the
time we got to
1988 uh the defense budget had eaten up
and then some all the domestic cuts and
uh the Republicans who were willing to
stand up for domestic spending cuts and
titl reforms and so forth were so de
moralized by seeing these massive
increases year after year for the
Pentagon that they basically threw in
the towel and the whole thing was kind
of a Wipeout if you want to get the
numbers on it just to kind of cap off
the point uh when Jimmy Carter left the
White House after all those years of big
spending by the Democrats first Carter
and then before him of course LBJ and
guns and butter and all the rest uh
domestic the domestic uh budget
non-defense was 15.4 4% of GDP so way up
compared to his historically when Reagan
left it was
15.3 so he he made one10 to 1% uh
difference uh and that's about all we
got done um you know I would recommend
everybody read uh the Triumph of
politics David's Memoir of his time uh
the subtitle is called why the Reagan
Revolution failed and it is if you're
interested in political economy as well
as gossip uh this is It's really one of
the Great Ms um but the book we're
talking about tonight is Trump's war on
politics and what uh Trump's war on
capitalism excuse me and this the title
says it so well there isn't even a
subtitle um why don't you start by
telling us you know what was Trump's war
on capitalism he is a businessman he
talked about having the greatest the
biggest the best economy ever uh you
know when he was president and things
like that what's the what's the essence
of Trump's war on capitalism well um the
question I think you were getting at is
why did I write it and the answer is I
had already written three War uh three
books trying to expose uh the fact that
Donald Trump isn't remotely an economic
conservative doesn't believe in small
governments I don't think he believes in
uh free markets and certainly he had no
Affinity whatsoever for sound money or
or fiscal rectitude so in 2016 I wrote a
book called Trump to warn people in 2018
I wrote another book called Peak Trump
uh to say that I was right and in 2020 I
wrote a third book called dump trunk
dump TR Trump uh and you know I figured
uh you are starting to sound like the
Buffalo Bills in the Super Bowl this is
your fourth one no I was starting to
think that well the fourth time would be
the charm right and my book came out
five days before the Iowa primaries and
it was too late so yeah uh but there is
a bigger point to it and that is you're
we're never going to get the kind of
government I think that all of us
believe in the kind of society the kind
of Liberty the kind of economic
Prosperity the kind of market capitalism
and so forth unless there is an honest
contest in the process of democratic
governance in the United States between
one party that more or less lines up as
the government Party The Party of the of
State uh the party of the political
class the bureaucratic class the appara
in Washington and there's a second party
that represents the hinderland and all
of the impulses that go with us uh to
leave us alone to tax us less to spend
less to intervene less to get out of our
way uh to allow you know uh the private
society and economy to breathe so we
really need a government party uh
contesting with an anti-government party
the problem is today we have a unip
party in terms of the career leadership
of the Republican party in Washington
when I look at McConnell who's been
there 55 years on the government payroll
I can't really tell you know any
difference between him and uh you know
our senator from New York uh the leader
on the Democratic side and so uh what I
think the great danger is that the
problems in the United States today in
terms of our position in the world which
is a disaster in terms of our public
debt we can get into a lot of those
numbers in a minute uh in terms of a
rogue Central Bank that is totally uh
out of control that uh if we want to
address any of that then uh we can't uh
have a continued uh rule of the uni
party we need to break it up but Donald
Trump despite all of his uh you know uh
rhetoric and all of his loud uh uh uh
you know you know boasting about
draining the swamp and being The
Outsider and coming in uh to clean up
the whole thing is just as much a
statist uh when it comes to all the key
issues and we go through them in the
book uh as most of the mainstream
politicians in Washington so the last
thing we need is not um you know a fight
in 20 24 uh between Trump and Biden it's
a pointless it's useless we need to have
a clean break in the Republican Party
blow it up if we have to and not allow
the second party in our democracy to be
Trump aied because if it's Trump aied
then we get more of what we had during
the four years that he was there I've
got a lot of data on that but let me
just cap it here with one and then we
can go in into some of the details um
when Trump became uh it was sworn in the
public debt it was 20 trillion already
and it had been swelling rapidly for
several decades when he left it was
close to 28 trillion so let's just call
it 8 trillion in four years now someone
might ask you know we when we have
numbers like this just like you were
saying Nick numbers of this magnitude
are almost hard to grasp uh to
understand but here's how to understand
it the first 8 trillion equivalent to
the 8 trillion that Trump racked up in
four years had taken from the first day
of the Republic to 205 to acrew that is
the first 43 presidents in 216 years
generated 8 trillion of public debt
Trump replicated that in four years not
only uh because of you know huge tax
cuts that he didn't try to offset with
spending but because of the whole
disaster of the pandemic the Co the
lockdowns and 65 trillion worth of uh
you know bailout and relief and uh free
stuff that came out of the effort to try
to tell people yeah we're sending
everybody home but don't worry we'll
send you money too so uh that that's the
heart of the matter anybody that could
generate 8 trillion uh in four years of
additional public debt equal to the
first 43 presidents and there were some
real Rascals obviously in bad guys uh in
that lineup including FDR and LBJ and a
lot of others in between uh that's
that's the kind of number that grasps
you uh by the collar and tells you uh
you know this guy is part of the swamp
uh he's not part of the solution what uh
just briefly what is wrong with running
up massive debt especially if the
government you know where if the United
States dollar is still the reserve
currency of the world um you know it's a
lot of debt but hey we can kind of cover
it just briefly yeah yeah I think those
are great questions someone asked me
that in 1970 when I first went to on
capital Y I ran for congress in 1976
against the deficit Jimmy Carter or I
mean the outgoing uh Ford deficits which
were large and the question was raised
and here we are and it's now uh you know
34 trillion and rising and so maybe it's
no problem after all no the answer is
there are two ways to finance the
deficit both of them bad the first way
is the honest way you finance it in the
bond pits by borrowing out of the
private savings stream the effect of
that though everybody understood when I
was first on Capitol Hill in the 70s and
into the early 80s that when you finance
the public debt deficits the honest way
it causes crowding out it forces up
interest rates higher and higher because
whatever the given supply of saving is
at the moment uh you know the Uncle Sam
has the sharpest elbows gets first call
on the money uh the crowding out happens
rates go up that's where we got the
famous Bond vigilantes and so forth and
that's why actually when we were trying
to cut taxes in the early 70s the what I
call the College of cardinals the
established season Republican leaders in
the house Bob Dole Senator dommin people
of Howard Baker who was the Senate
leader people of the they said no we've
got to be careful here because if we
Finance all of this tax cut uh with red
ink and borrowing we're going to crowd
out private uh investment we're going to
hear from our car dealers that can't F
you know Finance their lot we're going
to hear from our home builders that
can't whose customers can't get
mortgages and so and so forth so the
point is if you finance it the honest
way you cause crowding out you get an
early reaction economically
you basically uh suppress productive
investment and you shift society's
resources to government uh investment if
you think that's a word and I don't I
think it's an oxymoron so uh the other
thing about it that's really important
to understand without getting too deep
into this but it's why Trump is so bad
is that in the honest way of financing
the deficits which by by the way had to
be done in the late '70s in early ' 80s
cuz Paul vuler was sitting in the uh
chair at the fed and he was not about to
monetize the debt uh and as a result uh
we had an environment in which the
political reaction function if you want
to use that kind of term the feedback
was almost instantaneous and
early run big deficits drive up interest
rates in the bond pits those spread to
the banking sector those spread uh to
the hometown car dealers and home
builders and SNL bankers and you know uh
just regular consumers uh and it causes
a political reaction that uh it tends to
uh create a constituency in the
political system in Congress for uh
reigning in uh the deficit that okay
that's the first way the second way is
to you know issue all kinds of public
paper and have the Central Bank buy it
okay that's called monetization and
that's exactly what we've been doing
ever since the late 70s or late 80s
effectively after vulker left and let me
just give you some idea of how much has
been monetized when Greenspan took over
and you remember this is 1987 he was
allegedly at one time a great believer
in the gold standard and an anran
disciple and a lot of other things he
sort of lost his economic virginity
somewhere along the uh you know know he
was kind of a nerdy CL think we're
paying for the abortion now
right he he was some kind of nerdy
clarinette player who couldn't get the
girl and he decided that um uh if he was
the toast of the Town in Washington it
might work out better it actually did
but in any event uh the the balance
sheet of the fed and this is important
to understand was 200 billion and this
is
1987 so uh you know that's something
like 70 years years of the fed's
existence it taken 70 years to get to
200 billion and I'm going to talk a lot
about the balance sheet of the fed and
people say well that's what kind of you
know what does that mean why is that
such a big deal the balance sheet of the
FED is simply the track record of how
much cumulative money they've seized out
of thin air printed uh you know a Fiat
credit uh over time so we had 200
billion to to cut this story short until
they be decided that inflation was out
of control about a year ago and began to
pull back the uh the balance sheet of
the FED had reached 9 trillion now this
is in a lifetime I'm looking out here I
can see probably quite a few people that
might have been around in 1987 and uh
we're all here tonight and you went from
billion uh you know uh to the 9 trillion
that's
45x 45 times growth in that uh period of
time several decades at a point when the
GDP was only uh increasing by 5x okay so
when the money printed by the FED goes
up 45 times and the size of the economy
goes up five times you are way way way
out of kilter out of skew uh and it is
that massive continuous money printing
which monetized all of the debt being
created by
uh you know a uh Reckless Congress in in
White House that allowed us to continue
to run these huge uh budget deficits
year after year but eventually it
catches up with you as well in other
words you know there's this famous thing
in um I think it's Hemingway's book
where you know he's asked uh how did you
go one of the characters ask a lot I can
see you shaking your head a lot of
people know this one how did you go
bankrupt and uh the answer was slowly at
first then of a sudden okay and uh what
I'm trying to get at here is the uh
honest way to finance the deficit uh
will cause problems very quickly what
we're doing is the slow way but we've
created massive Financial bubbles
massive um you know uh misallocations of
resources tremendous amounts of
speculation uh that should never happen
in a healthy the economy and wouldn't
happen and it's permitted this to go on
much longer than would have been the
case if we had done it the honest way
but uh now now we're at the point uh
where I think the chickens are coming
home to roost because even the FED has
stopped printing money because the
inflation was out of control so to bring
it back to Trump you know Trump made a
big uh deal about you know caring about
the Forgotten man talking about Main
Street versus wall Street all of that
your book you know makes the case that
whatever he's saying he's actually
helping kind of Wall Street of the
financial sector far more than you know
the productive SE uh production sectors
and service sectors of the economy talk
a little bit about his tariffs yeah uh
tariffs and his immigration policy and
the way that that in the name of helping
people like he's trying to help small
producers and is saying we're going to
keep China from dumping cheap products
here so you can have your your industry
here why is that wrong well you know
that's a great question and there's a
huge amount to unpack and if I get too
far off the uh beaten path here uh you
know reel me in and and we'll get to
some of the other points but the the big
irony about Trump is that he was The
Outsider who's campaigning against the
status quo The Establishment the Deep
State uh you know the political class
all and that all made for good res
rhetoric and it actually resonated with
the public but when you look at what his
policy Solutions are they have nothing
to do with draining the swamp Trump's
basic take on why all these people were
left high and dry in fly over America
and in the Rust Belt and why we lost
millions and millions of jobs and why
manufacture and has gone to China and
elsewhere his basic take is that this
was all due to the
to the U oper the work of Nefarious
foreigners that is foreign governments
that were cheating and unfair in their
Trade
Practices uh immigrants coming across
the border in hordes uh who were
allegedly bloating our welfare state and
undermining our economy and undermining
our security it's always the great thing
right immigrants are
simultaneously coming here for welfare
and that outworking us they're like you
know which is it right yeah but see so
the point is you can't you can have the
right theme drain the swamp then you
better go to the swamp and change the
policies ask what they are that have
caused all of this disorder distress and
failure and that would have pointed
exactly to the Federal Reserve because
it's been
official with its 2% Target and it was
that
[Music]
because if you have wage increases and
you have equal uh productivity gains
then the cost of production doesn't
change and uh you know a business can go
on uh and expand and Thrive without
raising its prices but if wages are
increasing dramatically R more rapidly
than productivity because you have a
control and here's a startling number
from 1970 when we basically you know
flushed sound money down the drain at
Camp David in 1971 actually Nixon um
from then until uh the present unit
labor costs in the United States have
risen
275% and as a result of that we have
priced ourselves out of both the
services Market because all all the
services have gone to India and other
low-wage countries to say nothing of the
merchand Goods Market uh that has gone
to Mexico and China and so forth I have
one little uh thing in the book that g
gives a pretty good example uh you know
IBM was the great monster of the Midway
at one point in terms of making the
computer hardware which is the
modern economy uh but between 1990 and
the present uh their employment in India
is gone from zero to about
180,000 and their employment in the
United States has been cut by more than
a third so uh that that's on the
services side to say nothing of what
happened to these massive year INE out
uh merchandise trade deficits why did
that happen it all happened because the
unit labor costs uh increasing at these
rates it happened because you had a
as we all fondly call him uh some very
bad advice he said okay we're going to
uh unlink the dollar from its uh uh base
uh from its link to Gold uh but don't
worry about that because the free market
will take care of exchange rates and
what that really meant was that if we
inflated too much domestically relative
to the rest of the world our exchange
rate would go down all of a sudden
Imports would cost a lot more more our
exports would be less competitive and
there would be a disciplining mechanism
a breaking mechanism that would prevent
uh you know huge increases in the trade
deficit and the offshoring of production
now that's what fredman uh told Nixon
now in theory he was probably right but
in practice he was utterly wrong because
what happened over the last five decades
is all the central banks of the world
have engaged in dirty floats and so
there never was a free uh Market in
exchange explain what a dirty float a
dirty float yeah it sounds kind of
intriguing yeah it sounds kind of
intriguing uh but uh a dirty float
basically says rather than let the
market clear in terms of the exchange
rate between say the dollar in the Yen
or the dollar in the Euro or the dollar
in the uh you know Mexican peso uh
central banks step in and try to Peg the
infl uh the exchange rate in a way that
they you know uh believe and it's uh
another part of the evil in the world
that we're dealing with sort of
Keynesian economics and Status economics
and so forth they believe if they Peg
their exchange rates low it'll help
their export factories uh it'll help
jobs it'll help Prosperity they can
export more to the rest of the world uh
and so that's called mercantilism and
what the FED has done after
1971 is spread a massive monetary
disease in the world called mercantilist
monetary policy and uh as a result of
that and I've got a lot of examples in
the book of why we've lost so much
production and jobs to Mexico to say
nothing of uh China is basically because
the FED said it's okay to manipulate
your currency it's okay uh to uh
increase your domestic money supply at
uh huge unsustainable rates because
we're doing the same thing here and so
as we flooded the world with Fiat
dollars as the fed's balance sheet went
as I said just in that short period of
time from 200 billion to 9 trillion the
rest of the world these other central
banks uh but particularly the Asian ones
and also the Persian golf oil uh Petro
uh Bank central banks bought in dollars
hand over fist but the the secret of
that whole thing is when they were
buying dollars to keep their exchange
rate uh from rising they were basically
uh uh creating their selling their own
currency to the domestic Market in other
words the Fed was exporting infl
inflation and the other central banks
reciprocated by buying up the dollars
and inflating their own money supplies
now why am I going into all this because
that meant that what fredman said was
the automatic adjustment mechanism of
the free market and exchange rates was
uh short circuited uh it was uh uh you
know blocked and so the adjustment never
came and as a result from
1974 onward we have not had one year of
a a trade surplus and it's gotten worse
and worse and over the period of time it
was 15 trillion of cumulative trade uh
uh deficits and if you even throw in the
the uh Surplus on current on services
that we have in the world is still 11
trillion over the last 40 years well
what is 11 trillion a big number well if
you put it in today's purchasing power
it's 20 trillion uh and so therefore
basically we have uh uh you know
borrowed 20 trillion from the rest of
the world to keep this whole game going
so that that's why um you know this is
how we got into the mess uh on trade and
this is why uh Trump as I say in the
book uh had it uh totally upside down
the problem was you know he would tell
you listen to the speeches it's these
nefarious evildoers in the trade us
trade uh Administration or in the
Commerce department or uh you know uh
lobbyist sneak sneak speaking around uh
the banks of the pomac that made bad
trade deals uh and gave away the store
uh with all of our competitors and
that's why we're in such a big uh mess
and that if you put a guy who really
knows how to negotiate and for instance
not pay his bills which was one of his
uh negotiating techniques if you put
some a tough guy like me in the uh Oval
Office I'll negotiate good trade deals
and before you know it everything is
going to be better well he negotiated
NAFTA as you all remember and there's a
lot of hoopla about that basically if
you look at it it just got a new name
nothing changed and secondly if you look
at what happened to the deficit with
Mexico it doubled after uh you know and
is that a bad thing though I mean he did
he renegotiated NAFTA and we kind of I
guess got worse terms on some level but
we got more stuff cheaply well yes but
you know the I think that's true but
there is a free trade position that says
don't worry you you know this there's a
certain kind of libertarian free market
free tra that that
ignores uh the monetary side of it right
and so it says well and there is this
point and I used to make it uh and I
think half of it's valid the other half
isn't the point we used to make in the
70s and 80s was well if other countries
are stupid stupid enough to fill their
Harbors with rocks you you know sort of
figuratively Stop Trade uh well why
should we uh reciprocate and be as
stupid as they are and so therefore if
they want to subsidize their exports
like the Chinese or others uh well more
more power to them because they're
basically transferring wealth to our
consumers uh uh domestic welfare uh is
better off and so that's fine well
that's half of the equation but the
other half of the equation is that when
you have a net export uh imbalance of 20
trillion over a period of time you have
exported a huge amount of your
production productive base to the rest
of the world and unless you can keep
borrowing at larg higher and higher
rates that isn't sustainable as an
economic matter first but as a political
matter and this is the point and you may
think it sounds a little flippant but I
don't think it is I think that Milton
fredman was the Godfather of Donald
Trump because Milton fredman basically
told Nixon sever the link to gold and
I'm a gold standard man I think you
might have noticed that uh and we don't
need to worry about uh the uh you know
ancient Relic or barbarous Relic or
whatever canes called it uh because we
have a market a free market that'll set
the exchange rates right well he was
wrong about that we exported massive
amounts of our industrial base and I'll
give one statistic on this that I think
is uh telling we ma exported massive
amounts of our industrial base we
created a burned out Zone in much of the
Rust Belt the Upper Midwest uh
Pennsylvania New England was long gone I
was from the auto state of Michigan and
you you know that that was totally
burned out but where did you know where
did Trump get elected in 2016 on the
margin he got elected in the russb
precincts of Pennsylvania uh of Michigan
of Wisconsin of Iowa uh in all the
places that got left behind because we
had an
unsustainable uh you know uh set of
Economics with the rest of the world and
it was caused by the central bank that
uh fredman was willing to uh let free
now fredman thought that all of the
central Bankers that is the members of
the FED would be just like him they
would be Milton fredman clones and they
would be very punctilious about you know
the rate at which they were expanding
Fed Credit and he had all kinds of rules
of thumb and so forth but of course that
was a you know that was a pipe dream
that was naive the people that get
appointed to the FED are basically uh
there to do the business either of Wall
Street of Washington po politicians uh
or Wall Street speculators and that's
essentially what we got I I feel a
little bit bad because the last one of
these recent speakes who we had was with
the biographer of Milton fredman and we
were generally saying nice things about
him so I feel like we're kind of
whispering uh but uh your point can I
say one thing okay I'm not really trying
to trash Milton Freedman because he's a
great hero I thought it was Trump's war
on Capital not fredman yeah uh but uh
was in terms of free markets and the
understanding the the rudiments of a
free Society you can't beat Milton
Friedman but the problem is he had a
view of Central Banking and a view of
the Federal Reserve that I think was
totally wrong and that uh became uh the
uh you know the fulcrum for all of these
things that happened one of the other
things you talk about I mean because
this all of certainly all the problems
with the Federal Reserve or the central
bank predate Trump and uh you know a
fascinating thing that you pull together
in the book is you note from 1947 to
2000 real growth uh annual economic
growth averaged
2.45% um since then it was under Bush it
was nine10 of a percent Obama basically
1% Trump 1% so you know whatever has
been going on in terms of economic
growth has been bad for a while but you
talk a lot about how tarp at the of the
Bush Administration and the beginning of
the Obama one handouts to uh automakers
I mean lock them into place so could you
talk a little bit about how Trump you
know and then Trump did something
similar with Co but is part of the
problem when you talk about the the
Midwest or the Rust Belt that these
parts of the world uh these parts of the
American economy haven't been really I
you know they end up owning uh creative
destruction like they just they they get
wiped out but they're not allowed to
change and adapt because they get
various kinds of programs that are
designed to help them kind of make it
through to the next paycheck or
something like that yeah well I mean
that's kind of the the the problem of
crony capitalism I for anybody that
might be interested I wrote a 640 page
book called uh you know uh on that whole
topic that was uh released in
2013 uh but I think you know the the
issue uh that we need to find a way to
understand is that everything goes back
to Central Banking and when the Central
Bank makes it so easy to borrow money uh
and we end up with a economy that had
when Greenspan left or got there there
was about 10 trillion of total debt on
the economy public and private this is
household business government Finance
okay and that was less than two 100% of
GDP today it's 96 trillion yeah okay in
other words they have kept interest
rates so low they've suppressed uh you
know uh they've had such deep and long
lasting Financial uh repression that the
economy has become a giant
lbo okay and when you do an lbo I was in
the private Equity business so I know
when you do an lbo there can be
prosperity for a couple years and but if
things don't work out right uh you're
going to have interest payments that
begin uh to and we're starting to see
that interest as a percentage of the
federal budget the uh for years the
interest on the federal debt was like
two or 300 billion it is now the Run
rate in the last few uh months has been
a trillion okay and it's heading to much
bigger to bring it back to Trump's
specific policies uh you know what uh he
came into office saying he was not only
going to stop illegal immigration but he
was going to cut legal immigration in
half what is bad about that why is that
part of a war on capitalism okay because
uh essentially it raises a whole issue
of supply side policy and I was a supply
Sider back in the 19 80s with Reagan and
then I got run out of the supply side
church because I didn't follow all the
precepts uh exactly but the issue that
we have today uh as to why growth has
been so tepid and why living standards
have sort of stagnated and why there's
so many uh very um alienated people out
there in the Fly Over America wanting to
get behind Trump uh you know the the
reason uh
that this has been happening um is
because we've got huge deficiencies on
the supply side of our economy in terms
of Labor and capital investment now the
native born foreign Workforce is
actually shrinking it peaked in 2015 and
it's shrinking and that's because for
better worse or for whatever reasons we
can get into huge cultural discussions
here uh uh native born uh women and
families are not having babies and so
our labor force is shrinking and since
historically half of economic growth GDP
growth has been labor the other half is
productivity um our econ economy is
grinding to a halt because the labor
Supply is shrinking unless we allow uh
immigrants who want to work to come here
and become part of the workforce now
this is how we got where we were at the
peak of things and I I I got a number
that I think is kind of startling when
you hear about the flood of immigrants
coming in and we're being overrun and
America's being uh you know somehow
turned upside down if you go to 1870 we
finally got R out of the the Civil War
and all the chaos that that generated
there were only 39 people 39 million
people left in America North South all
the states the union
reunited uh over the next um 40 years to
the eve of World War I we had 25 million
immigrants so uh relative to the
population in
1870 uh the Immigrant population in a
few decades was 2third of the population
they begin with now how many immigrants
do we have today we have legal
immigrants of about a million a little
over a million we have a population of
328 uh million people 335 million people
so immigration today is less than
onethird of 1% not 66% or 60% or 40% a
given year pardon in a given year yeah
but uh even in if we take 10 or 20 years
it's still a couple percent so that's
the first point the second point is we
have a totally broken
ridiculous uh immigration policy that
comes right out of the swamp in
Washington and that if Trump really
understood what he was saying when he
said I'm going to drain the swamp the
first thing you would do would be to
change the basis for immigration from to
get here you either have to be uh you
know a family unification which is about
400,000 out of the million or you have
to be a PhD or some tech uh Hightech uh
uh uh skilled worker to get a couple
hundred thousand more slots or and this
is the big or you have to be a refugee
or an asy and that's the only way that
unskilled workers can get into the
United States today when we desperately
need unskilled and low-skilled worker
because our Native Workforce is
declining last year the last year that
the data is available 2022 only
4,000 green cards were issued under the
category I think it's called E3 and E6
uh for unskilled worker 4,000 out of the
million
118,000 legal immigrants that got here
to say nothing of the hordes that are on
the
border now the hordes On the Border if
you look at the uh you know if you can
stand it you look at Fox News every
night uh you know most of them are
pretty uh strong backed able-bodied uh
young people and their families or
middle-aged but it's it's a unskilled
low-skilled Workforce looking for a job
and a better Economic Opportunity but
it's the policy is equivalent and I
wrote about this in my uh Blog the other
day it's equivalent to trying trying to
drive a dump truck through a pinhole in
other words there's millions of people
at the border trying to come in there's
only 4,000 slots for unskilled workers
so all of them are at the border being
forced to pretend that they're Ayes that
they're refugees and the only way you
can become a refugee is to cross the
border break the law get arrested and
then uh be put into the queue that takes
months and months in fact years uh of
determination in a totally clogged up
court system uh in order to uh get
certified that you're a ass Asylum
seeker and to prove that you have to
prove for
instance that if you come from Co Costa
Rica as an example uh you're uh in uh
endangerment of life and limb if you
stayed uh I bring up Costa Rica because
um I checked the other day a couple of
my family members were down there in
vacation
seems to be the hot spot uh and it turns
out you can get a ticket from Costa Rica
to Kansas City if there was some job
openings there for
$214 on Delta okay um so if we had a
guest worker program of the kind that
makes so much sense today that would
allow people to go to the US counil it
in Costa Rica uh get a guest worker
permit and be matched up with someone
looking uh to have uh hire people for
lawn care work or warehouse work in
Kansas City they could get there for
$214 no fuss no mus uh you know no uh
chaos at the border uh no uh uh you know
uh border patrol uh people chasing
around in the middle of the night uh and
we would open up that little pinhole uh
to the economic rationality that we need
to have in other words if they simply
reform the system to B to make it
economics based rather than Asylum based
which is politics make it economics
based and you have a guest worker
program and if people come here and they
they're making a payroll and their
employer is certifying it month after
month year after year uh for 10 years
I'd say give him a citizenship and let
them say and stay and the whole problem
would be solved the hordes at the border
are millions of people that want to be
economic immigrants that are being
forced to be political refugees and
they're creating a mass and the reason I
mentioned the
$214 uh Delta ticket is you got to to
get from Costa Rica to the tech real
grand you got to pay the coyote $4,000
to
$10,000 to get you there when Delta
would be happy to do it for 214 if we
were only smart enough to have a
rational economics based
uh immigration system but there you go
again immigration control the whole
Byzantine
convoluted uh uh control system is
statism at its worst it's run by uh the
lobbies in Washington Google gets
everybody they want they get all the
phds they get all the smart young
techies coming out of uh you know South
Korea or Taiwan or wherever else they're
coming from they they take care of their
needs the Fortune 500 takes care of
their needs because there's four or five
categories for advanced degrees phds
unusual uh skills blah blah they all get
in 3 or 400,000 a year but employers
that need to have people working uh in
fast food joints uh or in lawn care
businesses or in warehouses or in
agriculture can't get anybody here
legally so you get the whole that we
have today um I've got uh one more
question before we go to uh the audience
um so you in in the book Trump's Warren
capitalism you also you talk about how
he uh Trump who you you define as a
caesaris politician he's like Caesar uh
very Imperial in that sense he
overreacted to covid both in terms of
lockdowns and signing off on that but
also giving people lots of money not to
work which you know Lord knows I want to
be in that situation someday but it's
probably not good public policy um
defense spending he's a big advocate of
more and more defense spending
regardless of uh the actual threat to
the uh National Security or our borders
but my question for you before we go to
the audiences so Trump is awful I I
can't speak for this audience I know for
myself I didn't vote for Trump I don't
expect to vote for Trump I'm not moving
to Canada and I'm not moving to Cuba if
he wins or anything like that but who
isn't the other alternative as bad or
worse if because it's going to be Joe
Biden yeah uh and or is this just this
way you have like your next book half
written already right where it's like B
for yeah well well first of all uh if
you have to suffer through another
Democratic Administration might as well
have a scile uh guy uh in the chair uh
because very little is going to get done
but that's a little uh factious but we
have to start thinking I think from our
point of view in the world that four
years is not the end of history and that
if we don't get a non-statist or an
anti-statist party reassembled realigned
out of the mess of the unip party that
we have today well then there really is
no hope because uh you know you will
continue to do the same whole thing over
and over again uh which Einstein said
you know is the perfect definition of
insanity so I say um what we need to do
in 2024 is blow up the Republican party
it needs to be purged it is a gang of
you know uh cultural uh right-wingers uh
neocon
warmongers and basically careerist
politicians who use the party is a
fundraising do you still consider
yourself a
republican uh well I you know I I think
no this party this party needs to go
okay you know this is a Libertarian
audience broadly so explain quickly too
you talked about social conservatives
and stuff like that in the book you
mentioned you know the drug war is
stupid can you just give us 10 seconds
on that what's the zud film version of
why the drug I'll give you three seconds
the drug war is really godamn stupid
okay uh and and again this is part of
the whole Trump stick you know he came
down the escalator in 2015 talking about
the uh murders and the rapists and the
drug dealers coming across the border is
I lay out my book quite clearly if the
drug part of it is a problem uh you know
uh deregulate uh drugs and let uh the
teamsters ship the stuff in and let
Philip Morris distribute uh keep it uh
legal I think they're they might even be
post alria now they're like their 10th
name change yeah I know well the old
Philip Morris okay uh so bring it above
ground make it legal uh take out all the
U premium profit that basically goes to
funding the criminal organizations that
are necessitated when the government
decrees that a a desired product shall
be artificially scarce so that you know
that's part of all the rhetoric too I
mean everything you hear about all the
drugs coming across um you know that is
a different issue and we need to
separate them out uh the economics of
immigration versus the economics of the
stupid War on Drugs and the drug control
laws that we have um and uh you know the
fact that until people don't probably
remember this I don't think any of us
could we're not been around long enough
but until 1918 you didn't have to have a
passport to come to America okay there
was no passports there were I like to
blame my parents for that change once
they got in they're like okay this this
isn't work all all of this uh you know
uh immigration control uh really uh
began uh then and it's created its own
uh you know its own bureaucracy and its
own set of Poli politics so if we got
back to sort of economically driven
border policy which is what we had to
our great benefit until uh 2023 or 1923
when they passed the first Immigration
Act uh half of the most of this problem
would go away but even if we did and I
had a little thing about this the other
day I I was sort of about maps and I
said hey you know uh this terrible thing
that's going on right now they're trying
to get 60 billion more for this you know
utter uh Insanity of the Ukraine proxy
war and they're tying it to 15 billion
of more border control money for the
right-wing Republicans so that somehow
the uh you know uni party can scrape
together the money it needs to keep the
forever Wars going in Ukraine so I said
well let's look at some of the maps and
most of it's about Ukraine we won't get
into that now but I said here's a map uh
it's a map of Mexico and where the US
culat are located and there's actually
10 of them and they're spread all over
Mexico and I said could you imagine what
would happen to the crowd at the border
if you were allowed to go to the counsil
or Embassy in your area and apply for a
guest worker permit just like you can do
now uh to get a Visa if you're a skilled
worker or to get a Visa if you're the
the wife of a American citizen uh who
got stranded in Argentina some way uh if
we could if we used this massive expense
and most of it I think is a waste of our
state department and all of our
embassies and all of the councils we'd
have everywhere if we put those
bureaucrats to useful work which would
be to interview and vet people who
wanted to get a guest worker permit and
also make it possible for them to
connect digitally or otherwise in this
modern world with employers or their
agents in Kansas City or Spokane or
Detroit Michigan um what would happen to
the um you know 300,000 a month or
whatever encounters they're having at
the border what my answer is it probably
go down to about 5,000 a month and it
would be who would be left well drug
dealers criminals and insane people uh
as uh you know Trump's always talking
about so 95% of the business at
in terms of the hordes at the border
would disappear because they would be
handled not in just Mexico as one
example they would be handled by the US
culate uh system all over Central
America uh Latin America and elsewhere
in the
world uh let's go to audience question
um why don't we uh Morgan can you uh go
back here to uh
Daniel
and uh please just ask a question sure
uh you mentioned when you were talking
about the monetary system and economics
how you thought some Libertarians were
too focused uh on issues not related to
the monetary system but don't you think
you are committing the same mistake but
in the opposite direction of blaming
everything that's happened negatively
economically in the US on the Federal
Reserve and on the monetary system isn't
the decline of some Industries and a lot
of economic changes that happened in the
US simply the fault of relative changes
in population productivity comparative
advantage around the world and evolution
since World War II uh yeah there I mean
I'm saying it's not the only thing going
on but the the honest to goodness fact
is it is the main thing going on that is
Shifting the location of economic
activity yeah technology changes but if
we weren't
inflating uh the domestic wage cost
price structure and we had investment
that we need uh the technology change
would not cause Business Industrial
activity or business activity to migrate
to Mexico if they're assembling cars or
to China if they're making uh you know
uh computers or Apple products that
wouldn't happen it could happen here but
the two things that we have and I was
getting into that is we have a
constricted supply side one because
uh we don't have the labor two because
we have the inflation that has caused an
export of our industrial base and three
because there's so much speculation
generated by easy money and all the
money printing by the FED um that uh
we're not getting domestic
investment uh in technology plant
equipment uh Workforce upgrades and so
forth that would allow us to remain
competitive and I'll give you one number
that I think uh again it's uh part of
the indictment of the Trump
era from about 1955 to
2000 the um average rate of net business
investment net real business investment
now every part of that phrase is
important real because you take the
inflation out of the numbers in net
because if you're simply replacing the
Capital stock you're consuming this year
that is depreciation amortization that
doesn't get you anywhere that just keeps
you where you are but the net numbers
that the Commerce Department publishes
are after depre are gross capital
investment after depreciation after
amortization after inflation the number
during the Trump four years was 3/10 of
1% not 1% 3% or
5% uh as it was historically but it
was3 so uh essentially 15th of what the
historical Norm was so what we got
during the Trump four or five years is a
vicious anti- supply side program anti-
supply of
labor anti- supply of competitive goods
from abroad and anti- Supply inter terms
of investment in productive plant and
Equipment Trump was you know boasting
all the time about the stock market
being Skyhigh but that was because all
of the capital in the system was being
diverted to speculation on Wall Street
Financial engineering if you look at the
increase in stock BuyBacks if you look
at the increase in dividends earned and
on earn if you look at the massive uh uh
explosion of m& a activity most of it
totally unproductive just putting
companies together and then they take
them apart four years later and both of
them are claimed to be in the
shareholders interest if you got the the
financial engineering out of the system
the capital would be flowing uh to uh
productive investment but it's not
because of the Federal Reserve therefore
too much speculation and financial
engineering too little investment and
then because of import policy
immigration policy uh too little uh uh
labor to make Goods here and then we're
even taxing uh consumers for the goods
that were uh required to buy let uh go a
question up
here oh hold on I'm sorry I was actually
pointing behind you hi there my name's
uh Brooke and and in 1990 I went to
Japan to run a trading desk for Mar
Lynch and the thing that I observed um
back then it was Japan not China right
there was eating our lunch was how easy
it was for us to move Capital into Japan
and yet labor couldn't move into Japan
and it was hard to get Capital out of
Japan you could get profits out maybe
but not capital you could put IP and I
think what you're saying is that really
labor has to have freedom to of motion
first and then Capital can follow and I
agree with that so here's my theoretical
question and I'm looking forward to this
right because ever since and I think it
was under Carter we not Carter um
Clinton we have we we've made it uh
student debt impossible to discharge and
bankruptcy now what if uh China Europe
Japan the rest of the world just said
look it's not a crime to discharge
student debt in bankruptcy if you're an
American come here you can't be
extradited right so we lose all of our
native because I I see you know you you
I have a border in you know I rent a
room to a to a
55-year-old who's working as a Night
Nurse to pay off student loans oh my God
so she can eventually not die right and
I'm
like yeah I think there's probably a
bigger story there than uh no there
isn't and you're talking to somebody
have a history of doing
that on the point about this guy who
your guy still work and I didn't say
what the gender was Nor mine so um the
but but I think that that's a way for
the market to actually adjust because if
these countries do that we're going to
have to face the fact that we're doing
the wrong thing I think is what we're
talking I couldn't agree more and about
your guy who's working you know there's
actually several million people on
Social Security who are in danger of
having their social security Tech check
garnished because they're behind on
their student loan repayments okay and
some of them are never going to make it
now the bigger point I'm making is that
uh the 1.8 trillion or whatever the
number is now that has been pumped into
the system for uh student loans since
the 1990s when the thing really took off
is basically subtracting labor Supply
from our economy because people become
Perpetual students they really do and as
long as you're in student status you
don't have to Service uh or pay back
your loan and so one of the numbers that
I looked at I look at uh is and without
getting buried in it right now we I look
at the real unemployment rate in America
and the way I get it is I take the uh
total adult population let's say 18 to
70 and I calculate the hours at a
standard work year 2,000 hours a year
and I get a number and then I look at
the number that the labor department
says labor hours they actually track
this that are being used and the uh
today in our economy and the answer is
the unemployment rate on an hour's basis
for the total population forget about
whether the BLS is they're in the labor
force or not in the labor force forget
whether they're on disability because
they got
a Corporal tunnel problem with their
left finger uh forget about whether
there students at 35 still working on
their second PhD if you just take it on
on an hour's basis for the total Society
because people ought to work and support
themselves the unemployment rate is
40% and the 40% unemployment rate is a
function of welfare state policies that
subtract uh that delete labor Supply
from the market because you get a
student loan or you're getting the whole
package of welfare benefits or you're
getting early retirement under Social
Security uh etc etc so half of the
problem that we have to deal with here
is a kind of welfare state
blob that is drastically undermining the
supply side of the economy by causing
huge speculation and financial
engineering to dissipate capital on Wall
Street and driving labor out of
productive employment on Main Street and
when you have Capital uh that's uh uh
being uh depleted and when you have
Labor that's being depleted and shrunk
then you don't have a good recipe for
Prosperity uh and you you have
another you have another picture you
have another part of the analysis as to
why statism
is ultimately uh the problem uh that
we're dealing with uh a question sir yes
uh first as as one who greatly applauds
your main concerns uh
strategically I believe that it's that
it's true that you want us all to vote
for RFK Jr absolutely desite fact RFK
senior is not available yeah because
he's not despite the fact that he's daed
on the subject of climate change could
you outline that brilliant strategy of
why we've got to vote for that guy okay
that's that's where we were getting all
night and I never got there slowly we
turn okay well I I just to put it a
little biographical the first campaign I
worked on as an anti-war SDS student
protester in 1968 was rfk's candidacy
for the presidency on the ground that he
wanted to bring the Empire home uh and
he was the anti-war candidate so here we
have RFK Jr and we have the same problem
only far worse today but my uh reason
for supporting him is that the beginning
of addressing all this means you got to
have a tough skeptical uh attitude to
the fed and he does I'm advising him
privately on a lot of things and I know
from conversations that he does and
second you have to understand we don't
need a $900 billion defense budget a 1.3
trillion total National Security Budget
if you count everything and we need to
drastically U re rain in uh the Empire
and all the bases and all the he share
your um vision of uh you know free trade
and uh free movement of people uh I
think uh he's uh not you know he's not
where he needs to be on everything but
uh you know I I think you have to start
with the fiscal monstrosity that we have
and recognize there's a two-step thing
to deal with it one is defense we should
cut that by four or 500 billion you know
when uh Eisenhower said U warned about
the military-industrial complex
everybody knows that speech he gave in
1961 when he was leaving if you put the
defense budget of that day which was at
the peak of the Cold War the height of
the you Soviet Union actually was
functioning still at the time uh that
number would be about about 400 billion
today in current dollars of purchasing
power and Ike said that's enough in fact
he said you know the danger is we're
going to spend too much and if anybody
knew about war and anybody knew about uh
really understood defense President
Eisenhower did the budget today is 900
billion in the same dollars of
purchasing power and we don't have a um
you know uh industrial State uh
technologically empowered uh enemy like
we have had then you know the GDP of
Russia is 2 trillion ours is 26 trillion
the GDP of China is 15 trillion ours is
26 but China would you know collapse in
six months if their exports were cut off
so they're not going to uh just briefly
where where do you both parties you you
know you pointed out everybody believes
in more defense
spending uh I think everybody
understands the existential threats to
the United States are have not been
growing you know what explains that kind
of you know the willingness of either
the Democrats or the Republicans to just
keep goosing well I I think at the end
of the day it's the military-industrial
complex in the fact that the defense
budget is like a self licking ice cream
cone okay uh there is so much money
dripping off the sides of the cone uh
going into the uh think tanks and the
Nos and the whole apparatus of
Washington that then comes up constantly
uh with reason
for more with uh threat assessments that
are total baloney I mean you know really
what what is the threat from Russia to
the United States today and if it's a
threat to Germany then the Germans can
arm themselves and they basically were
spending 1.3% of GDP and buying their
gas uh until we convinced them to join
the Ukraine proxy war because they
didn't think it was a threat okay so uh
the the point is is going back to the
question about RFK you've got to bring
the Empire home you if you take the 400
3400 500 billion out of Defense uh and
then stop all the interventions because
remember we're spending 350 billion a
year on Veterans alone and that's just
the Deferred cause of War all these
people that uh come home and uh they're
permanently disabled or uh economically
disabled we have to support them
medically uh in come wise and so forth
but that's a cost that ought to be
charged to the defense budget and it
isn't so uh you have to bring that home
and if we do that then I think you can
start to piece together some other
things I do not think from my
conversations that RFK would be opposed
to a stronger means test on Social
Security and Medicare for people that
really sh you know with 100,000 300,000
a million 10 million of income should be
getting it uh and so that would help in
a big way because when you think about
how much we're spending on those two
programs alone something like 20
trillion over the next uh 10 years if
you put a means test at the top of the
income scale you would take you would
take a lot out of that but you really
have left the supply side church right
so now it's cutting government spending
really is more important than reducing
taxes well at the end of the day that's
where Milton was Friedman was right he
said the ultimate measure of you know uh
the government uh problem is the
spending level and uh that's another
beef I have with Trump uh you know at
the peak in 2020 and we didn't get into
it a lot and I wish we could have but
it's in the book uh when it when he went
into the whole lockdown and then they
bailed out uh everything with these
massive stimulus bills spending uh
reached uh you know 40% of GDP uh at the
federal state and local level that's
European social democracy level I mean
Trump between 2019 the budget federal
spending was 4.4 trillion in 2020 was
6.6 in 2021
6.8 so that's a massive increase and
that's just the federal level but also
you know there was so much bait being
put on the table to the states if you uh
you know expand your Medicaid we'll give
you more matching so you really have to
look at the federal state uh local uh
the public sector okay and it did reach
40 uh trillion I mean 40% of GDP another
way to look at it is uh the the worst
kind of spending we do even though it's
socially necessary and why it needs to
be constantly uh you know contained
constrained is transfer payments and on
the eve of the covid lockdowns which
were totally unnecessary uh the transfer
payment rate and if they publish this
every month of federal agencies was 3.1
trillion
which is money that was flushing uh in
from either borrowed or taxes flushing
into Social Security Medicare food
stamps housing all the rest of it at all
levels of
government uh when they passed the cares
act and Trump said you know cash is on
the way relief Is On The Way by April
2020 the transfer payment rate had gone
from a steady state of about 3.1
trillion to 6.6 trillion and then in
December Trump deci you know signed a a
second installment of the covid relief
and uh in the campaign said we got to
give everybody another
$2,000 per uh person check uh which most
of it was paid for in the third
installment which Biden happened to sign
and he called it uh you know the
American Rescue act or whatever but it
was simply the last installment of the
Trump covid release bail out free stuff
the reason I mentioned it is that when
that became effective in the spring of
2021 the transfer payment rate from
government in America Rose to 8.1
trillion at an annual rate in other
words from three to eight and so the
difference the five trillion difference
and they wonder why we have inflation
because all the transfer payments
weren't even buying Public Works uh they
weren't you know they weren't buying
anything they were simply money that was
being uh basically extracted from future
taxpayers and printed by the FED uh you
know slushed into the economy uh to
create you know these numbers I think
can at some point uh you know you can
start to lose patience with them but the
the point I'm trying to make is what
happened during 2019 2020 2021 is out of
this world it's off the the historic
economic and fiscal radar screen and all
of it generated because Trump had no
principles and Dr fouchi comes to him
and says you know the pandemic's at hand
uh we need to lock down the economy
close the schools shut down the
restaurants and bars and malls and so
forth and Trump said okay let's do it
and uh we were Off to the Races that
that was an Unforgivable sin okay I'm
mainly trying to do analysis here but
when it comes to preaching at the end of
the night the unpardonable sin the
unforgivable sin was the whole covid
lockdown uh policy and the and I buy
very strongly here the Harry Truman
Doctrine he had the plaque on his desk
it said the buck stops here uh all of
that happened because Trump uh embraced
it endorsed it tolerated it uh and uh
let it happen I can't believe that
anyone who was even a kind of milk toast
um you know uh Republican uh what what
do they call the uh rhinos Rhino yeah I
was trying anyone who's even a milk
toast Rhino would have thought you know
we're going to destroy the business of
millions of people that have been
working for decades building up their
local restaurant or uh uh gym or
whatever else it might have been and
we're just going to shut them down and
Destroy them we're going to tell people
that they can't go to the mall even if
they're healthy they can't go to a gym
if they're 25y old weightlifter uh you
know a even a as I said in the book a
half-ass republican would have said wait
a minute we can't we can't do that and
Trump basically and this is goes to your
point ni uh he's a cesarian and by that
he thinks the great man on the horseback
or sitting in the behind the Resolute
desk is going to make a whole the whole
difference uh he's the guy that can
negotiate he's the guy that can sit down
with you know uh the leader of Korea or
China or whatever and that is that's the
danger yeah uh we've got time for one
last question yes okay one of the
offsetting factors of all this
regulation and spending has always been
the underground economy very much
dependent upon cash and we're seeing
less and less cash so a underground
economy still exists is it going to grow
or is are we going to lose it and then
also the other thing is we've got all
these immigrants coming in this country
what are they all
doing well I think most of them if they
were if they were legal and they were
given a guest worker permit would be
working that's why they're coming here
okay but since they that's illegal and
they have they if if you go across the
border get arrested get in the queue for
an asy asylum uh determination you're
not allowed to work for six months
period And if something's wrong with
your paperwork after six months and
you're still waiting in the queue which
almost all of them are you still can't
work okay so we're basically making it
impossible but if you're a blue State uh
city or a blue State Governor uh what
you're doing doing is opening up the
hotels and opening up the soup kitchens
and everything else uh for the people
who are coming here who are not allowed
to work because it's against the law
it's so damn stupid and crazy that you
have to wonder how uh how you know
people can uh really not understand
what's going on but that that's the
that's where I think we are
yeah yeah do you think uh is the
underground economy um growing shrinking
will be become more difficult to do in a
world of uh kind of Technology enabled
or Central Bank enabled surveillance
yeah I think uh the mo the most
dangerous thing that anybody's talking
about at the present time is abolishing
cash and of course uh when you hear
people talking about uh government uh
digital currency or the need to get rid
of cash there was a big movement on a
while ago from all the Keynesian
Keynesian economists who said we got to
get rid of cash because that's the only
way we can you know fine-tune the GDP uh
if we uh don't allow cash to flush
through the system and uh behave in ways
that we uh don't approve so uh the
campaign uh to abolish cash or to
replace it with digital uh cash which
isn't at all the same thing uh you know
dollar
dollars that are in all our pockets here
are bare or currency your name isn't on
it your social security number isn't on
it but it's accepted uh as hand toand uh
uh money because uh that's what we all
uh understand you get rid of that the
underground economy practically
disappears and the powers that be say
well we're doing this to get rid of all
the bad things like terrorists and drug
dealers well I don't know that the
terrorists are using that much uh cash
and uh you know the drug dealers I
understand they like the Discover card
because it has you know really good well
features interest rates yeah um can I
ask just to wrap things up you know the
book is Trump's war on capitalism I
highly recommend it it has a forward by
RFK Jr who like Trump and Biden I will
not be voting for but I appreciate
you're making the case your career has
kind of as you were pointing out has
done this kind of remarkable circuit
where you know when you were in the 60s
when you were uh younger and beginning
your career you were pushing for you
know an end to the Pentagon or a
critique of that a critique of what used
to be called the welfare Warfare State
um and you've come back to that I my
question and you you in the book and I
think tonight you've made really strong
cases about why things are so kind of
you know screwed up and everything but
are we living in a better world than we
were in 1968 materially and kind of
morally and just on a day-to-day basis
and if so how do you account for that
capitalism yeah uh you know this is the
one thing you get whenever you point out
what's wrong with the state driven
policy and you know the fed and deficits
and trade policy and so forth well
you're better off now than you were 20
30 years ago but it wasn't because of
the state intervention it was just
despite the state intervention in other
words capitalism is dynamic people want
to improve their circumstances they
invent things they create Enterprise
they find better M straps all of that
continues and that's what keeps the
economy crawling forward inching higher
uh but what what the problem is is when
the state gets too big too strong uh too
um you know uh too too interventionist
it's it slows that down in fact uh maybe
even slows it to a crawl so uh yeah
we've we're we're clearly better off
materially I don't know if we're better
off morally okay but we're clearly
better off materially because that's
what capitalism does and the thing is
you can't allow the politicians to claim
credit for what is happening silently
day in and day out uh through the length
length and breadth uh of a market
economy that's Now 26 trillion big and
you know 100 trillion worldwide all
right we're going to leave it there
David Stockman thanks for talking to
reason thank
[Music]
you